et on débute avec la situation sanitaire
en france est un point sur les derniers
chiffres santé publique france dénombre
30 1621 une nouvelle contamination au
qu'ovide en 24 heures à la france
devient le premier pays d'europe à
dépasser la barre des trente mille
infectés en une journée
88 personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 12,6 pour cent réa
prêts à les annonces des manuels macro
hier le premier ministre jean castex et
plusieurs membres du gouvernement ont
précisé en début d'après midi la mise en
application des nouvelles mesures
sanitaires
les détails avec robin peu l exercice de
pédagogie pour jean castex comme
empruntons pour les mesures de
confinement le premier ministre a
précisé la mise en application des
restrictions annoncées la veille par
emmanuel macron jean castex est
notamment revenu sur le détail du
couvre-feu imposé entre 21h et 6h en ile
de france et dans huit métropoles qui
entre en vigueur dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi face aux progrès de
l'épidémie le gouvernement a également
rétabli l'état d'urgence sanitaire
une situation qui élargit certaine
mesure à l'ensemble du territoire
national
des mesures générales s'appliqueront
partout puisque tout le territoire
national sera désormais placée en état
d'urgence sanitaire
ces règles qui s'appliqueront partout
sont les suivantes toutes les fêtes
privées comme les mariages ou les
soirées étudiantes qui se tiennent dans
des salles des fêtes dans des salles
polyvalentes ou tout autre établissement
recevant du public seront interdites
tous les restaurants de france
impliqueront le protocole sanitaire qui
a été récemment renforcées et prévoient
notamment la limitation à 6 du nombre de
clients par table et l'enregistrement du
nom des clients pour faciliter le
contact racing dans tous les lieux
vous êtes assis comme les cinémas les
stades les cirques où les salles de
conférence la règle d'un siège sur deux
devra s'appliquer
gérald darmanin a détaillé le dispositif
de contrôle mis en place par le
ministère de l'intérieur
douze mille fonctionnaires de police et
de gendarmerie seront mobilisés pour
faire respecter le couvre-feu dans les
zones concernées
en cas d'infraction restrictions les
forces de l'ordre pourront verbaliser
comme lors de la période du confinement
sanctions qui sont appliquées au moment
où les gens ne respectent pas d
interdiction de ce couvre-feu de 21h à
6h qui ne s'applique que dans les zones
évoquées par monsieur le premier
ministre
une amende de 135 euros ce bien la même
amende que pendant le confinement et si
jamais il devait y avoir réitération
c'est dire si au bout de trois fois les
policiers ou les gendarmes arrivent à
confondre une personne qui par trois
fois fraude ou ne respecte pas ces
règles d'interdiction six mois
d'emprisonnement possible et 3750 euros
d'amendé
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires entre
en vigueur pour une durée de quatre
semaines et pourrait s'étendre au moins
jusqu'à la fin du mois de novembre
si le parlement donne son aval à une
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
alors ce couvre-feu cela signifie donc
l'arrêt de l'activité du secteur de la
restauration à partir de 21h et les
restaurateurs sont très inquiets et
écouté on a eu dans un premier temps la
fermeture des bars à 22 heures on
pouvait continuer un peu l'activité
parce que notre activité majoritaire
était la restauration maintenant on doit
fermer à 21h économiquement
je pense que y'en a plein qui vont
mettre la clé sous la porte
la majeure partie du personnel à partir
au chômage partiel parce qu'on n'a pas
le choix c'est pas avec 2010 qu'on va
pouvoir travailler ni pour voir moi ce
qui m'ennuie le plus c'est justement
cette ou ces charges fixes je sais pas
comment on va les honorer quoi les
loyers tous les abonnements connaît et
tout ça j'ai aucune idée traîne que mon
loyer ça va me coûter vite à neuf jours
d'activités voilà sur une semaine donc
ça fait ça fait plus d'une semaine donc
après les deux semaines et demie qui
restent ou trois semaines dans le moi
qu'est ce que je fais j'arrive à payer
trois fournisseurs et puis et puis et
puis en fait à être déficitaire et le
soir ils mangent pendant une demi heure
les gens soir c'est pas trop laxiste pas
comme le dit le midi les gens y viennent
ils mangent d'une demi heure trois
quarts mais moins pour moi je sors pas
marché pour les gens il va rentrer en la
matière chez eux ils vont se faire à
manger chez eux je pense pas que j'ai
une hygiène reçu rang 18 heures alors ce
couvre-feu vise notamment à éviter la
saturation des hôpitaux l'épidémie en
effet mis en lumière les problèmes de
l'hôpital public manque de personnel de
lits de matériel le personnel soignant
est à bout et réclament plus de moyens
une journée de mobilisation nationale a
eu lieu ce jeudi voyait les précisions
de notre reporter bassam chez lui ils
étaient des centaines à avoir répondu
favorablement à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale pour défiler dans les
rues de paris
ici dans le 7e arrondissement un cortège
qui a débuté dans les quatorze heures
pour aller jusqu'au ministère de la
santé ces personnels soignants qui en
appelle au gouvernement pour revaloriser
leur métier pour demander plus de moyens
plus de personnel mais surtout plus de
10 et faire appel au gouvernement pour
reconnaître la pénibilité de leur emploi
martin hirsch avait déclaré à quelques
jours que les personnels soignants
devait sacrifier leurs jours de congés
pendant la toussaint pour venir à bout
de cette crise sanitaire et venir en
renfort le premier ministre jean castex
a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'une prime
allant de 110 à 200 euros bruts pouvait
être versée par jour de congé non pris
de ses personnels soignants une annonce
qui a pas satisfait l'ensemble des
personnels soignants je vous propose de
les écouter nos collègues sont épuisés
c'est la signification d'un campagne
qu'on vient de lancer avec notre
fédération
épuisée pourquoi épuisé parce qu'on leur
demande tellement depuis des années
depuis des années ils mettent leurs
jours de repos sur deux comptes et par
un temps parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas les
prendre
les 100 euros c'est pas une réponse
politique c'est une réponse de castex me
pardonne d'épicier c'est une réponse
d'épicier nous on n'en veut pas nous on
veut des projets on veut voilà du
personnel on veut un plan sur plusieurs
années
on veut vraiment que l'hôpital public
qu'ils soient sauvegardés voilà ça c'est
super important
je sais qu'il ya un secteur privé c'est
pas le problème mais l'hôpital public
c'est l'assurance que tout le monde sera
soigné quel que soit votre religion vous
revenu votre couleur de peau un petit
cortège donc est parti de la place
vauban dans le 7e arrondissement pour se
terminer quelques mètres plus loin
devant le ministère de la santé
beaucoup prise de parole beaucoup de
témoignages des témoignages de
personnels soignants sur la pénibilité
de leur travail sur leurs journées à
rallonge sur les manques de moyens les
manque de lits et les difficultés qu'ils
ont quotidien à l'hôpital
voilà beaucoup de témoignages pour faire
appel au gouvernement pour reconnaître
la pénibilité de ce travail ils ont
déclaré rester maintenir ce mouvement
tant que le gouvernement ne répondra pas
favorablement à leurs revendications et
prendra enfin en considération la
pénibilité de leurs fonctions la mise en
place du couvre feu décidé par
l'exécutif face à la recrudescence du
coït 19 va à nouveau changer le
quotidien des français et plus
particulièrement celui de nombreuses
professions comme les restaurateurs les
gérants de bars les professionnels de la
culture ou encore hey les policiers on
décrypte la situation tout de suite avec
nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christophe prudhomme urgentiste au samu
de bobigny porte porte parole de la m us
et l'association des médecins
urgentistes de france bonsoir à vos
côtés william maury policiers secrétaire
général du syndicat option nuit bonsoir
avec nous également frédéric jeanjean
patron de la brasserie les templiers à
marseille vous êtes également le
secrétaire général de l'ump a gelé dans
les bouches du rhône c'est l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie
bienvenue sur l'antenne de rtl france
alors frédéric jeanjean ce couvre-feu
imposé en île de france mais aussi dans
plusieurs grandes villes comme à
marseille certains disent eh bien que
c'est la mort de votre profession les
aides promises de l'état vont elles
permettent de vous soutenir écoutez les
aides qui sont promises pour l'instant
on aimerait bien qu'elle se concrétise
lorsque monsieur grise est venue à
marseille il y a de cela une dizaine de
jours il avait déjà annoncé l'aide qui
montrerait à hauteur de 10000 euros
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a toujours
rien qui soit proposée de manière
tangible et marquer nous attendons de
voir précisément ce qu'il en sera je
rappelle qu'à la fin de l'été
à la fin de du confinement on nous avait
proposé des aides pour le matériel dans
le cas de la distanciation physique et
que quand nous avons déposé les dossiers
bien nous a répondu que les enveloppes
avaient été épuisées donc on est assez
curieux de savoir comment cela va
évoluer et très inquiet pour le devenir
de nos professions je vais vous donner
une anecdote très simple ce soir à
marseille au tribunal de commerce à
l'initiative du président et des juges
il y avait une réunion pour informer les
chefs d'entreprise sur toutes les
procédures qui peuvent exister aussi
bien discrétionnaire que les procédures
qui sont publics pour les aider à passer
cette phase ce cap
parce que on crâne qui est vraiment
naufrage aux franges de non pas de
quelques entreprises mais de tout tout
un tas de filière alors christophe
prudhomme on entend bien l'inquiétude la
colère depuis l'annnonce de ce
couvre-feu dans les lignes les plus
touchées par le quoran à virus en même
temps plus de 30000 contamination ces
dernières 24 heures on voit que les
chiffres augmentent
est ce que c'est une mesure sanitaire
qui a fait ses preuves
non absolument pas serait aujourd'hui il
faudrait que le gouvernement réagisse en
prenant en compte la réalité sur le
terrain
effectivement aujourd'hui de virus
circule mais il fit et circule dans des
lieux qui ont été identifiées et ce sont
les entreprises et en particulier les
cantines des entreprises les universités
et les effectivement les rassemblements
familiaux ou festifs donc plutôt que
d'utiliser la grosse bertha du
couvre-feu vaudrait mieux à utiliser des
armes plus adaptée et ciblée
parce que là on a une situation qui est
difficile à l'hôpital c'est vrai mais
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement n'a
rien fait pendant la période que lui a
laissé un peu de répit que l'une est
celle commise pendant l'été faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons - moins de
soignants moins de personnel à l'hôpital
comment être janvier c'est ça la réalité
et si une crise à l'hôpital c'est pour
ça et c'est l'indicateur le plus fiable
voyez aujourd'hui c'est l'incapacité
aujourd'hui de notre système de soin de
prendre en charge à la fois les
patientes classique et les patients
atteints par coville il est patient
n'était pas le quodidien pas de
catastrophe le discours alarmiste du
gouvernement écouter aujourd'hui nous
avons un peu plus de 1600 patients en
réanimation
nous étions à 7000 fin mars début avril
7000 donc effectivement il faut prendre
des mesures pour éviter la circulation
du virus
mais ces mesures généralisée qui sont
mal comprises par la population vont
traîner des refus de la part la
population de les adopter
alors que les mesures ciblées qui sont
comprises sont plus facilement adoptée
par la population sont beaucoup plus
efficaces
écoutez voyez fermer toute vie sociale à
partir de 21h quand va-t-il se passer
dans le métro
entre 20h et 21h des rames bondées
est-ce qu'on se contaminent à la
terrasse d'un café afin à marseille où
il fait encore bon on peut prendre son
café à la terrasse à l'extérieur et à
l'extérieur la vie sont très limités
donc voyez ce sont des mesures que ne
comprenais pas nous souhaitons des
mesures ciblées et puis les mesures
ciblées c'est pâques à tergnier à la vie
sociale c'est aussi bien son mea culpa
sur l'échec de la pratiquer des tests et
sur le fait qu'il faut généraliser
maintenant très rapidement des tests
rapides
vous savez ce matin dans les échos les
transporteurs aériens s'étonnait de la
politique du gouvernement français qui
interdisait les tests rapides dans les
aéroports donc on continue à faire des
tests dont les passagers ont les
résultats 48 heures après donc pendant
48 heures il se promène et si seulement
quand il aura le résultat du test si on
appuie les joies 48 heures après alors
que si on fait un test rapide a sorti de
l'avion et bien en 20 minutes vous avez
le résultat
si vous êtes positif et bien vous isolez
pendant sept jours alors christophe
prudhomme on va y revenir dans un
instant sur ces mesures ciblées une
chose est sûre demain minuit début du
couvre feu
william maury vous êtes policier votre
profession on l'entend alerte sur ses
conditions de travail ces derniers temps
alors vous qui travaillez nuit avec vos
collègues comment est ce que vous avez
appréhendé cette nouvelle mission qui
vous est confiée
il a dénoté un petit peu c'est que pour
l'instant on n'a eu que des retours sur
le co vide
au printemps on avait fait beaucoup de
honda en avait fait beaucoup de
commentateurs d'aménagement on avait
expliqué aux gens donc on arrive en
terrain petit peu ce qu'on va dire un
terrain conquis
les gens savent que voilà le couvre-feu
et des mis en place mais j'ai la seule
crainte qu'on peut avoir au niveau des
forces de l'ordre et est ce que des gens
vont encore une fois joué le jeu est ce
que les gens vont comprendre cette
nouvelle mesure puisque ça fait des
semaines qu'on n'entend qu'eux il n'y
aura pas de reconfirmer là on a pu
discuter un petit peu avec la population
sur sociaux des dernières heures on nous
explique que c'est la goutte d'eau alors
c'est je ne sais pas comment on commence
à être interprétée moi je travaille
demain soir je pense qu'il va falloir
passer par des grandes discussions avec
les gens pas tomber dans le répressif
immédiatement
voir un petit peu sur les va dire on
laissait passer le week end vendredi
samedi dimanche pour voir comment la
population réagit à cette nouvelle
annonce du gouvernement
voilà on va pas se positionner tout de
suite au niveau des forces de l'ordre en
disant il faut faire ça il faut faire ça
je pense qu'il va falloir éduquer ce
qu'on avait fait au niveau 2 en au
printemps dernier pour voir comment ça
peut se passer c'est qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui c'est que les gens ne
comprennent pas cette mesure où nous
allons pas l'appliquer un petit peu
difficile aujourd'hui alors beaucoup de
gens que vous avez croisé qui ne
comprennent pas cette mesure inique ne
sont pas les seuls pas mal de réactions
politiques depuis la prise de parole des
manuels macron je vous propose de
regarder celle de jean luc mélenchon 60%
des contaminations liées au travail ou à
l'école ou à l'université entre 8h et
19h mais ma croix interdit les sorties
au bar et au resto entre 20h et 6h
effectivement christian christophe
prudhomme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
c'est d'abord les entreprises selon view
les écoles les universités où finalement
les foyers de contamination sont les
plus fréquents dans ce cas là quelle
mesure faudrait-il prendre selon vous
écouter des choses que nous avons déjà
les tous avaient les mesures à prendre
si la population est convaincue que les
mesures sont efficaces et bien l esaa
note vous savez moi je travaille en
seine saint denis jean les transports en
commun tous les jours et dans le tramway
qui est bondée où nous sommes très
proches les uns des autres on peut pas
respecter le mètre de distance tout le
monde porte un masque tout le monde
porte hamas parce que les gens sont
convaincus que c'est utile par contre là
moi je crains le pire
et pour répondre à notre collègue
policier
je crains le pire dans des zones comme
la seine-saint-denis parce que un
couvre-feu à 21h c'est pas compris par
la population c'est vraiment pas compris
par la population une population qui se
lève très tôt le matin pour aller
travailler beaucoup de gens qui sont au
chômage dans des logements qui sont
surpeuplés et donc interdire aux gens
d'être d'or après 21h mais qu'elle
risque d'être dehors
21h c'est le moment il ya le moins de
monde à l'extérieur donc on a moins de
contacts rapprochés
voilà donc en santé publique vaut mieux
prendre des mesures moins coercitives et
qui sont acceptées par la population
avec la population effectivement
adoptera la politique du bâton en santé
publique ne fonctionne pas il faut de la
conviction il faut que les gens soient
convaincus que les mesures qui
restreignent leur liberté et leur vie
quotidienne leur vie sociale et bien
sont utiles quand la population
considère que ces mesures ne sont pas
vraiment complètement efficaces et bien
il y aura des réticences des conflits et
s'est fortement dommageable parce que
aujourd'hui bien effectivement nous
avons besoin que le gouvernement se
mobilise sur les vrais sujets il est
vrai sujet aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement des mesures si vous alliez
à la fois des mesures de restrictions
sociales d'une politique de test et
l'armement de l'hôpital pour pouvoir
gérer cette épidémie qui va durer au
moins jusqu'à l'été prochain donc ce
n'est pas les 4000 lits promis par
monsieur verrons au mois de décembre qui
vont être suffisant alors que ce
gouvernement j'assiste depuis que
monsieur macro est au pouvoir
huit mille lits ont été fermés dans les
hôpitaux c'est ce qui me manque
aujourd'hui dans mon établissement que
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
le directeur général a un bilan social
monsieur martin hirsch dramatique 3400
suppressions d'emplois en trois ans donc
voilà pourquoi nous sommes dans cette
situation aujourd'hui il faut le dire et
c'est pas en utilisant effectivement un
langage martial et le couvre-feu qu'on
réglera le problème c'est pas que le
couvre-feu
ce sont des mesures de confinement cible
est comprise par la population qu'ils
appliqueront c'est une autre politique
de test et c'est des moyens pour
l'hôpital s'est pas uniquement ces
mesures qui sont prises à la va vite
non c'est pas pour quatre semaines six
semaines et qui vont tuer la vie sociale
et je peux vous dire la vie sociale la
vie sociale et le fait qu'on soit obligé
de déprogrammer dans les hôpitaux nous
constatons déjà une hausse très forte
des pathologies psychiatriques et si
l'hôpital n'est pas en capacité de gérer
offre à la fois les patients habituels
et les patients atteints de la maladie
coville on rit savoir
mortalité générale pour ces patients
qu'on va laisser un petit peu à
l'abandon qui risquent peut-être dit
dans un an deux d'être supérieure à la
mortalité liée à la maladie commis de 19
frédéric jeanjean donc un hôpital qui
risque d'être saturé voilà pourquoi
toutes ces mesures sont prises
le protocole sanitaire a lui été
renforcée dans les restaurants avec
notamment cette fameuse limitation à 6
du nombre de clients par table c'est ce
qu'a précisé le premier ministre
quel est votre regard sur cette mesure
est ce que d'autres solutions auraient
pu être trouvé or écoutez je vais
répondre simplement déjà un autre notre
ami qui est médecin et porte-parole des
urgentistes
il faut pas rêver il ne faut pas rêver
vous parlez de la réalité nous mêmes
quand monsieur vers en est venu à
marseille
nous voulions proposer le protocole
sanitaire renforcée tel qu'il est mis en
place
aujourd'hui quand il est venu il a
refusé de nous rencontrer
il a refusé nous adresser la parole il a
fallu une semaine de mobilisation avec
tous les professionnels que nous
attaquer en justice l'arrêté du préfet
pour qu'enfin nous puissions être
entendue avec le risque que le
gouvernement se retrouve avec un texte
qui soit rejetée par le conseil d'état
et c'est à ce moment là qu'on appliquait
ce que nous nous préconisions nous avons
une semaine de fermeture
ce gouvernement n'est pas dans la
réalité vous leur parlez de la réalité
des lits qui ont été supprimés vous nous
louent leur part lors de notre
quotidienne de ce que nous vivons de ce
que nous connaissons de ce que nous
pouvons faire de ce que nous savons
on n'est pas des génies on n'a jamais eu
cette prétention là on aurait pu nous
écouter on aurait économisé beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup d'énervement et
beaucoup de procédures mais vous savez
il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire ce soir je m'inquiète
on nous annonce et on appris ce matin
que monsieur vers en venez à marseille
faire une émission sur une chaîne
concurrente avec madame salam et
personne n'était au courant et on nous
annonçait qu'il serait face à des
français et on a invité un parlementaire
haut moi pas trop à marseille mais comme
mois plus tôt
dans les médias on a invité un humoriste
qui fait les scènes nationales et on
nous annonce que c'est ça la france du
quotidien écoutez moi je veux bien tout
comprendre je suis toujours pas un génie
depuis tout à l'heure mais enfin au bout
d'un moment on commence quand même à
ouvrir les yeux alors la réalité du
terrain elle concerne aussi les
policiers le premier ministre annonce la
mobilisation douze mille hommes des
gendarmes des policiers est ce que ça va
suffire pour faire respecter le
confinement comment comptez vous vous y
prendre on parlait tout à l'heure de ces
zones dites sensibles
est ce que les gens vont l'accepter est
ce que vous allez avoir les effectifs
nécessaires
william reymond tant d autres des
effectifs nécessaires je suis pas sûr
qu'on lisait puisqu'on les a toujours
pas actuellement il faut pas rêver la
nuit on en sous-effectif c'est pour ça
que option nuit ci a été créée en juin
dernier parce qu'ils menaient 6 qu on
voit aujourd'hui la salle et 96
dernières heures que le travail de nuit
enfin tout le monde en parle tout ce qu
on arrive sur des situations dramatiques
les situations dramatiques et la
délinquance a va pas s'arrêter parce que
on a une mise en place d'un couvre-feu
dans les zones dites sensibles
le couvre-feu il faut pas se leurrer
c'est ainsi respectée qu'à moitié et
encore je suis gentil quand big c de 50%
on va se retrouver face à des sanctions
la police qui vont être épuisés des
gendarmes qui sont fatigués parce que le
travail de nuit est usant et aujourd'hui
quand on demande d'avoir des effectifs
supplémentaires pour faire ce travail là
cette charge de travail là qui va nous a
comblés en plus de tout ce qu'on aura à
traiter
on nous dit que finalement on aura pas
d'effectifs supplémentaires
donc on veut bien tout faire on est tous
de bonne volonté on est on veut tous que
cette situation de cette crise sanitaire
ce serait le au plus vite mais il ya un
moment il faut aussi mettre les moyens
il faut aussi écouter la base il faut
aussi écouter des personnes qui sont sur
le terrain comme des médecins comme les
policiers comme tous les acteurs sociaux
qui sont face à cette crise sanitaire
pour décider ensemble il ya des choses
qu'on pourra faire des choses qu'on
pourra pas faire
des rassemblements dans des appartements
à 50 personnes comment on va pouvoir
régler cette problématique en pleine
nuit je voyais on m'expliquait tout à
l'heure sur une chaîne concurrente que
dans le dans le protocole et dans le
constate dans les autorisations entre
eux sortir son chien moi très bien moi
je veux bien que les gens sa trachée
mais dans des zones dites sensibles
comment on va faire pour expliquer aux
gens que nous voilà ils peuvent sortir
leur chien mais pas toute la nuit
parce que si on a des regroupements avec
une quinzaine de chiens avec une
quinzaine de personnes comment on va
leur expliquer de rentrer chez eux
puisqu'ils le temps n'est pas limité
donc c'est des problématiques
voilà on sait qu'on va pouvoir les gérer
au coup par coup parce que on va faire
remonter des informations mais on aurait
pu les les anticiper voilà moi la
problématique c'est vraiment que on a en
a peu d'effectif la nuit à montpellier
moi je peux vous en parler j'en parle
tous les jours parce que c'est des
choses qu'on dénonce voilà depuis
quelques mois maintenant
en france c'est la même situation quand
vous retrouvez avec deux ou trois
voitures aux trois cent quarante mille
personnes
il faudra achever la délinquance du
quotidien il faudra gérer en plus ce
couvre-feu là alors la délinquance
risque de baisser parce qu'on aura
certainement moins de personnes dans les
rues
mais elle sera toujours présente la
délinquance a s'est jamais arrêtée d'une
lendemain parce qu'il y avait un coureur
donc on fait toujours plus mais avec
moins donc c'est ça qui est paradoxal
frédéric jeanjean il nous reste quelques
secondes on a vu les soignants
aujourd'hui dans la rue et vous les
restaurateurs est ce que vous êtes les
prochains gilet jaune
écoutez moi pour l'instant ce gilet bleu
si vous voyez un jeu le porte sur moi
vous savez nous quand nous avons entamé
la première démarche est ce que nous
avons fait c'est que nous sommes des
chefs d'entreprise et nous sommes nous
maîtres symboliquement sous la
protection du tribunal de commerce
ça représentait quand même entre les
hôteliers les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs les discothèques et tous
les fournisseurs près de 7000
entreprises
vous savez si demain il fallait faire
des actions ce que je ne pense pas utile
s'il fallait faire des actions nous
aurions les moyens beaucoup plus
importants que les gilet jaune mais
l'objectif ce n'est pas l'arrivée de
sortir de fait
une révolution l'objectif c'est
d'arriver de pouvoir travailler de
pouvoir continuer à créer de la richesse
parce que il faut quand même jamais
oublier que tout ce qu'on nous annonce
comme mesure c'est de l'argent qui n'est
pas donnée pour les forces de l'ordre
c'est de l'argent qui n'est pas donnée
pour les soignants et c'est de l'argent
que nous allons prendre sur la richesse
que nous créerons plus tard laquelle
richesses en france permet de payer le
chômage la maladie et les retraites
donc à un moment cet argent qu'on nous
dit nous distribuer c'est simplement
l'argent que nous verserons plus tard
qu'on nous donne par anticipation et
encore on nous l'annoncent pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore vu la
couleur d'un radis merci beaucoup
frédéric jeanjean d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'ud amis h 13
merci à vous et william maury secrétaire
général du syndicat de police option
nuit et merci à vous christophe
prudhomme urgentistes samu de bobigny
porte-parole de l'association des
médecins urgentistes de france
restez avec nous sur rt france nous
reviendrons sur les négociations du bric
site le négociateur en chef michel
barnier indique que lui a proposé une
reprise des négociations la semaine
prochaine à londres puis nous parlerons
du fmi l'organisation propose une
fiscalité renforcée pour les plus riches
afin de faire face à la crise sanitaire
a tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
était assez violente d'ailleurs entre
les russes et les américains alors que
j'étais destinée à voler avec les russes
mais une opportunité s'est ouverte de
faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens qui m'a envoyé
aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs
on est loin de la guerre des étoiles la
en est quand même dans une espèce de con
fraternité et de solidarité
l'exploration au sens large est une
activité en coopération internationale
où on se rend service entre nations qui
pourtant au même moment son sujet
d'embargo et de conflits géopolitiques
savoir est ce que l'homme peut vivre et
travailler dans l'espace est ce qu'il
existe de la vie ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de la terre
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que nous trouve le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française est toujours pas d'accord
concernant le bric si tu es les
vingt-sept sont réunis aujourd'hui et
demain à bruxelles londres se dit elle
déçue par les conclusions du sommet
européen
les négociations pourraient reprendre la
semaine prochaine comme le propose
l'union européenne
pour charles michel le royaume uni doit
appliquer le traité du bric site point
final michel barnier s'est dit lui prêt
à faire des concessions raisonnable
notamment sur la question de la pêche
écouter des dommages dialoguerait avec
mon homologue david frost et puis l'a
dit nous serons à londres pour la
semaine s'il le faut le week-end la
semaine suivante à bruxelles j'ai tout
cas ce que j'ai proposé à l'équipe
britannique de négocier intensivement
dans le peu de temps qui nous reste pour
atteindre autour de la fin du mois
d'octobre
l'accord que nous souhaitons pas à
n'importe quel prix mais là d'accord que
nous souhaitons et que le dirigeant
européen souhaité évidemment oui comme
on dit uk nous appelons le royaume uni à
prendre les mesures nécessaires
concernant l'accord de retrait ces
protocoles
ils doivent être entièrement mises en
oeuvre point final et c'est aussi une
question de crédibilité internationale
pour le royaume du show aux créations au
championnat chaque le début les tifos de
youtube en aucun cas les pêcheurs ne
pourraient être les sacrifiés de la
pêche a assuré le président emmanuel
macron pour en parler nous sommes avec
bruno margolle pêcheurs président de
l'afe de passer la fédération des
organisations de producteurs de la pêche
artisanale
bruno margolle merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors au sommet
européen emmanuel macron à 600 soutien
aux pêcheurs
est-ce que cela vous redonne confiance
pour la suite oui bonsoir oui bien sur
le fait que comment le président de la
république affiche commence son soutien
à la pêche et je l'en remercie
d'ailleurs c'est et c'est une bonne
chose et puis que les les négociations
se poursuivent tant question poursuivre
il ya de l'espoir
alors l'union européenne est prête à
faire un effort raisonnable sur la
question de la pêche l'un des principaux
points de blocage dans les négociations
sur sa relation poste briques site avec
le royaume uni est c'est ce qu'a indiqué
le négociateur européen michel barnier
est ce que la france peut se retrouver
seul sur ce dossier
terral a beaucoup à perdre bien entendu
que la france je pense que vis-à-vis des
27 c'est le pays qu'il est certainement
le plus impacté vis-à-vis des autres il
faut il faut impérativement que l'on
reste soudée il y a eu comme un groupe
du riz folle et les huit pays les plus
concernés par la pêche britannique les
eaux britanniques
il faut surtout pas que l'on veut que
l'on se dise où il faut garder l'unité
de manière à pouvoir continuer il
faudrait pas que la pêche soit vraiment
la variable d'ajustement et et voilà je
remercie michel barnier de tenir bon et
nous avons entièrement confiance jusqu'à
la fin alors le droit de la mer place le
royaume uni en position de force
qu'est ce que vous proposez vous
aujourd'hui en tant que pêcheur à
nouveau bien entendu nous demandons un
statu quo de continuer à pêcher comme on
le faisait 1
personnellement ça fait 40 ans que je
travaille dans dans les eaux
britanniques je vois pas pourquoi faire
on me retirer ce droit
du jour au lendemain j'ai rien demandé
moi j'ai pas demandé à ce que le bris
des britanniques sorte de l'union
européenne
quelles que soient les raisons pour
qu'aujourd'hui je demande tout
simplement enfin nous demandons tout
simplement à continuer à travailler dans
les eaux britanniques comme nous le
faisions les eaux britanniques ont
lire sont sondés zone très poissonneuse
et c'est clair que si on la manche c'est
quand même un endroit très un entonnoir
donc c'est le poisson pages passe dans
dans cet entonnoir est bon il n'a pas de
limites qui passe du côté anglais du
côté français le but du pêcheur c'est de
chercher le poisson et le poisson n'a
pas n'a pas de limites bien entendu il
passe suivant les cours en suivant les
marais suivant le vent et soie qui passe
et suivant les saisons
il passe d'un côté plus d'un côté que de
l'autre aujourd'hui même les coteaux qui
nous sont attribués
ça ne veut plus rien dire parce que si
on peut plus aller dans les eaux
britanniques pour pour les péchés ça n'a
plus aucun sens
très concrètement quelles répercussions
cela pourrait avoir pour vous pêcheurs
pour tous les pêcheurs de ne plus
pouvoir se rendre dans ces eaux
britanniques
la grosse problématique c'est que il va
la ligne médiane qui sépare la manche
comment tous les battous le fin mot à
dire que tous les états membres
tous les bateaux les hollandais et les
belges les irlandais qui pêchent dans la
manche
aujourd'hui ils vont tous se rabattre
bien entendu sur la côte française du
côté français il va y avoir des gros
problèmes de cohabitation de
surexploitation
honnêtement ça va être un très très très
compliqué un impact également pour les
consommateurs bien bien bien sûr un
impact très certainement bien sûr parce
que le le le si je prends la place
boulonnaise qui est là des centres
européens les plus importants qui traite
plus de 300 mille tonnes de boisson qui
vient essentiellement de l'ecosse 20 ça
ça et ça risque d'être compliqué pour
avoir la matière première bien entendu
donc commencé que les anglais concerne
que 20 % de ce qui pêche les autres 80%
s'est exporté exportés essentiellement
en europe même la france beaucoup la
france donc je pense que de ce côté là
ils ont beaucoup à perdre alors dans le
plan de relance européen il a été prévu
réservez un fonds de 5 milliards d'euros
pour couvrir les dégâts commerciaux et
humains justement du bric site
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de
votre côté aujourd'hui cette enveloppe
là je sais pas exactement à quoi
correspond un n'y a pas que la pêche
bien entendu il ya tout un tas
d'économies qui sont dépendants de
l'union europe de l'est des îles
britanniques
mais aujourd'hui c'est 5 millions de ces
5 milliards d'euros l'an est-ce que
c'est prévu pour en attendant de trouver
des accords parce que je suppose que
même si on arrive sur un odile qu'il y
aura des accords de quelque façon et on
sait pertinement que ça ne sera plus
jamais comme avant même si on trouve des
accords donc il va falloir patienter
plusieurs mois voire un an j'en sais
rien et pendant cette année là il va
bien falloir continuer à travailler dans
des conditions respectables et éviter de
perdre tous nos entreprises à terre
comme en mer
parce que à nos deals ça signifierait
que beaucoup d'entreprises seraient
beaucoup d'entreprises de marins
pêcheurs seraient obligés de fermer la
porte
bien entendu il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises en l'occurrence les
bateaux qui font la pêche au large sur
boulogne qui sont indépendants à 100 %
des hommes britanniques
si on prend les chalutiers aussi bien à
l'échelle luthier les pilleurs de long
va dire qu'ils sont inféodés à la
branche unipêche on va dire entre 40 50
% de leur production du côté britannique
donc ça va c'est indéniablement on va
perdre une bonne partie de la flottille
européenne je parle que de la france
mais européenne également merci beaucoup
bruno margolle pour votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes pêcheurs
président de l'afe de passer la
fédération à des organisations de
producteurs de la pêche artisanale une
crise sanitaire qui a engendré une
profonde crise économique et le fonds
monétaire international a publié son
rapport sur les perspectives mondiales
un bilan en demi teinte à la récession
devrait être moins importante que prévu
certes
mais le redémarrage ensuite plus lent
david khalifa avec katia brillant dans
son dernier rapport sur les perspectives
mondiales le fmi prévoit une contraction
mondial de l'économie de 4,4 pour cent
pour 2020 mais l'institution
internationale et mais l'hypothèse que
le virus soit plus difficile à contrôler
avec des répercussions possibles sur
d'autres pans de l'économie
dans le pire des scénarios les progrès
sur tous les fronts dans la lutte contre
le virus se révèlerait plus lent que
prévu
la conséquence sur la croissance
seraient alors désastreuses
en europe les mesures ciblées pour
éviter un confinement généralisée ont un
impact néfaste
le rattrapage économique sera laborieux
sur le vieux continent
le fmi prévoit une croissance de 5,2
pour cent de la zone euro en 2021
l'espagne et l'italie sont les deux pays
les plus secouées par la pandémie
les espoirs de rebond évolueront en
fonction de l'amélioration de la crise
sanitaire sur leur sol le royaume uni
fait face au double choc du coc vie 19
et du breakbeat les britanniques font
face à une deuxième vague de
contamination qui ne cesse d'entraîner
de nouvelles restrictions à l'activité
le royaume uni est devant une grande
incertitude et le pire est à prévoir
selon les économistes les aides massives
à l'emploi mis en place à partir de mars
vont s'arrêter fin octobre et un
mécanisme moins généreux valeur succéder
la crainte d'un bond record du chômage
est envisagée en france les économistes
craignent que la reprise s'essouffle
totalement jean castex a exhorté les
entreprises à signer massivement des
accords de réduction de l'actif
t afin de préserver l'emploi et les
compétences objectif premier du plan de
relance
une mesure pour éviter une explosion du
chômage dans le scénario du fmi le plus
sombre le monde va faire face à une
intensification des vague d'infections
les calculs du fmi sont effrayants la
perte cumulée de pib pour la période
2020 2025 est estimé à 28 milliards de
dollars dont onze mille milliards pour
2020 2021 et pour rencontrer cette crise
le fonds monétaire international appelle
à une fiscalité renforcée pour les plus
riches c'est l'une des conclusions
récentes du rapport du fmi portant sur
la surveillance budgétaire est l'un des
cosignataires du texte estiment que des
impôts plus élevés pour les ménages les
plus aisés les entreprise très rentable
pourrait servir à financer des services
essentiels comme la santé ou la sécurité
sociale le fmi recommande également aux
gouvernements d'être plus sélectif dans
leurs dispositifs de soutien de
l'activité
il les appelle à prioriser les emplois
de demain en investissant notamment dans
la formation et pour en parler à nous
sommes avec dany landes et économiste
membre des économistes atterrés
dany langue merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors taxer davantage
les plus riches
pourquoi le fmi arrive à cette
conclusion simplement maintenant en
pleine crise sanitaire
c'est un sujet tabou auparavant disons
que le fmi en la matière ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est que le fmi a
connu un virage lors des années 2010 sur
ces questions puisque on a eu des
rapports de ces experts qui disait déjà
dans les années 2010 que trop
d'inégalités était nuisible à la
croissance ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant par rapport au discours
habituel de l'institution qui nous
disait que finalement plus les riches
rich mieux ça à bruxelles je pense qu'il
y a
une prise de conscience progressive de
la part de ces experts et ses
recommandations sont extrêmement
intéressante alors le fmi fait également
comme recommandation de faire des choix
comme par exemple investir dans les
emplois de demain
est ce que cela signifie qu'il faut
abandonner certains secteurs a de toute
façon on est dans une crise économique
majeure mais on est aussi dans une crise
sanitaire majeure
il faut pas obliger il ne faut pas
oublier que cette crise économique est
lié très fortement à la dégradation de
la situation écologique qui était signé
le câble ça fait un certain moment que
les experts dans le domaine nous alerter
là dessus donc il ne faut pas oublier
cet aspect qui est qui est très
important et donc effectivement ça fait
sens d'orienter les emplois de demain
vers des emplois verts il faut
absolument qu'on fasse cette transition
écologique
c'est un réservoir d'emplois très
important c'est un réservoir aussi de
croissance et donc cette transition
écologique doit aussi passer par une
meilleure distribution des richesses
vous savez que ces dernières années tous
les plans de relance qui ont été menées
à différents endroits ont bénéficié
quasi-exclusivement 1 % les plus aisés
en particulier aux états unis et donc on
se trouve dans une situation où
effectivement il est plus que temps de
les mettre à contribution
parce que effectivement s'appuyer sur
les entreprises les plus rentables
finalement espérer que ces entreprises a
pas la face le le pas finalement du
secteur de secteurs dans le secteur plus
écologique ça ne fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui
non ça ne fonctionne pas avec les
intrigues les incitations qui sont
celles du marché et qui nous mène au
désastre et puis vous savez que les
entreprises les plus rentables sont en
grande partie est ce qu'on appelle des
gagas les gars femmes pardon google
amazon facebook microsoft et j'en ai
oublié or enfin donc c'est les gars
femmes qui sont des entreprises les plus
rentables et elles font tout ce qu'elles
peuvent pour éviter de payer des impôts
et leur objectif n'a jamais été de nous
garantir une transition écologique qui
ne peut être assuré que par
l'intervention des citoyens et donc des
autorités publiques
alors d'après le fmi le gouvernement
d'injecter près de 12 milliards dans
l'économie mondiale depuis le début de
la pandémie est 7 semble semble
faramineuses
est-ce qu'elle a été injecté à à bon
escient selon vous alors selon moi c'est
effectivement le problème de ces plans
de relance qu'on constate un peu partout
j'aimerais bien voir comment le fmi
arrive à 12 milliards en tout cas non
pas 12 milliards vous lisiez combien 12
milliers de milliards c'est sa douce
three lions mais là milliards douze
mille milliards j'aimerais bien savoir
comment il arrive à ces sommes par
exemple dans le plan de relance français
bon il ya des aides aux entreprises qui
sont nécessaires mais il y en a pas
assez sur la transition écologique et
sur la remise sur pied du système
sanitaire et on voit bien que dans le
cas français on continue de fermer des
lits alors que c'est le contraire qu'il
faudrait faire donc à mon sens il est
important de cibler ses adc plan de
relance et ce qui est intéressant dans
le rapport du fmi c'est que justement il
propose de cibler ses aides sur les
personnes les plus vulnérables celles
qui en ont le plus besoin et qui aussi
participent le plus à l'est à l'économie
de par leurs activités qui sont les
activités les plus essentiels et on l'a
vu au moment du confinement mais aussi
de par leur consommation
très concrètement comment est-ce que
cela ne pourrait se faire en france ce
vous bien écouter le orientant parler de
la planification c'est très bien on nous
annonce remettre sur place un plan et
c'est très bien et bien je pense que la
priorité absolue de ce plan et si on
décide de nouveau d'avoir un plan
quinquennal ça devrait être la
transition écologique et donc la dépense
devrait porter en premier lieu et avant
tout sur les emplois gère sur tout ce
qui concerne la transition écologique
l'isolation des bâtiments le filoutage
la réouverture des petites lignes et
tout ce qui est absolument essentiel et
urgent merci beaucoup dany lang d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste membre des
économistes atterrissent et dans le
reste de l'actualité les pays du g20 se
sont accordés pour suspendre la dette
des 73 pays les plus pauvres du monde
une suspension temporaire jusqu'à fin
2020 et qui pose problème à la banque
mondiale et aux ong qui réclament des
mesures plus significative est moins
handicapante pour ces pays est déjà bien
affecté par la crise du coronavirus
d'assen chaalis aider les pays les plus
pauvres de la planète à passer cette
période de crise sanitaire voici
l'objectif des pays du g20 réunis
virtuellement ce mercredi pour les
créanciers il y a urgence à savoir
éviter que la dette souveraine provoqués
par la pandémie de coronavirus se creuse
un petit peu plus déjà avant la crise
sanitaire la hausse des niveaux de la
dette publique inquiète est notamment
dans les pays les plus pauvres crise
sanitaire oblige les 20 pays les plus
riches du monde dont la france
l'allemagne ou encore la russie s'était
engagé en avril à suspendre le service
de la dette des états les plus
vulnérables jusqu'à fin 2020 mercredi à
l'issue d'une réunion virtuelle
organisée par l'actuel pays à la tête du
groupe
l'arabie saoudite le club des vingt a
prolongé de six mois jusqu'au 30 juin
le moratoire sur la dette des états les
plus pauvres de la planète
nous sommes convenus de prolonger
l'initiative de suspension du service de
la dette pour une durée de six mois
le groupe a aussi émis
l'idée d'une restructuration de la dette
des pays les plus démunis pour aller au
delà de cette simple suspension du côté
du fonds monétaire international même
son cloche avec pour objectif
d'accélérer l'aide aux pays les plus
déshérités
la communauté internationale doit faire
tout son possible pour soutenir les plus
vulnérables côté banque mondiale aider
les états les plus vulnérables est une
chose mais à la condition de mieux
contrôler les créanciers responsable en
partie de l'embout froment de ces pays
dans leur dette
la tendance lors des crises de la dette
et que les pays en difficulté passe par
des rééchelonnements inefficace qui les
affaiblit davantage les créanciers
accord des procédures de réduction de la
dette
mais un coup énorme nous devons
travailler mieux et plus vite cette fois
ci des mesures insuffisantes pour les
ong lesquels dénoncent des actions
insuffisante et inefficaces à long terme
pour l annuler la dette des pays les
plus pauvres de la planète représente la
seule solution le g20 c'est un pas
important aujourd'hui
mais il n'est pas allé suffisamment loin
ses membres auraient pu prolonger
l'arrêt du service de la dette jusqu'à
la fin de 2021 pour aider les pays les
plus pauvres à lutter contre cette
pandémie mondiale
ils ont simplement choisi de ne pas le
faire avec le chaos économique causée
par le coc u19 qui menacent de faire
reculer la lutte contre la pauvreté de
plusieurs décennies
la prolongation de la suspension du
service de la dette était le stricte
minimum que pouvait faire le g20 le fait
de ne pas annuler les paiements ne fera
que retarder le tsunami de la dette qui
engloutira de nombreux pays parmi les
plus pauvres du monde
aujourd'hui 46 de 73 pays les plus
vulnérables du globe la plupart
africains ont déjà fait une demande de
suspension en 2019 la dette de ses 73
pays a augmenté de 9 5% selon la banque
mondiale pour atteindre le montant
record de 630 2 milliards d'euros
cette même institution qui a rappelé
mercredi que 150 millions de personnes
pourraient basculer dans l'extrême
pauvreté d'ici la fin d'année 2021
en résumé si les grandes institutions
monétaires mondiales se veulent
rassurantes avec une reprise en 2021
les répercussions de cette crise
sanitaire devrait se faire sentir sur
plusieurs années
au détriment des pays les plus exposés
aux créanciers internationaux
restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
le nouveau plan détaillé par jean castex
ses ministres au lendemain de l'annoncé
d'un couvre-feu de 21h à 6h en ile de
france et dans huit métropoles du
territoire à partir de samedi puis nous
parlerons de ce fameux couvre-feu et ses
conséquences sur le quotidien des
français à la solidarité prime tel sur
nos libertés individuelles ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à tout de
suite
[Musique]
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et et la préparer
il ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pub pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux il
ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
exemple
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe
c'est à dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant mais
on recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura un débat éthique
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois je me suis dit mais c'est pas
possible c'est rien plus rien pendant le
temps on voudra nous enfermer tout seul
dans ses cuisines et bains je me suis
aperçu que c'était bien plus difficile
qu'ils avaient une équipe de 25 usiniers
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel de
rire le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
monde d'avant il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver pensé que
ça allait me rendre plus tolérante et ça
m'a rendu plus intolérant alors pour
elle c'était d'expansion je voulais vous
poser justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du malheur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune et colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des jambes qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tram va décider de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions
au niveau international il y rend en
grave difficulté au plan économique et
social pour la chine c'est une très
belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences
les iraniens avait t'il un autre choix
face aux pressions américaines en tous
genres par notre incapacité à répondre à
ces attentes légitimes ne les avons nous
pas pousser dans les bras d'un
partenaire qui va en profiter pour faire
de l'iran sa tête de pont au moyen
orient
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que des gants dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information
il est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 15 octobre 2009 annoncé hier
explicité aujourd'hui instauré samedi le
couvre-feu prend forme et bientôt vie
tout au moins en ile-de-france et dans
les huit métropoles les plus touchés par
le cos vide
jean castex et ses ministres ont
détaillé ce nouveau plan du gouvernement
en début d'après-midi les soignants eux
étaient mobilisés dans la rue
aujourd'hui
l'hôpital public mise à rude épreuve
réclament davantage de moyens à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sera rétablie à
partir de samedi un couvre-feu a donc
été instauré en ile-de-france et dans le
bi métropole une mesure qui pourrait
être étendue jusqu'au 1er décembre cyr
le parlement l'autorisait outre le débat
sur l'efficacité d'une telle mesure pour
freiner l'épidémie ou sur le caractère
opportun d'une éventuelle décision
politique à gauche comme à droite un
débat parlementaire est réclamée alors
le couvre-feu porte-t-il atteinte à nos
libertés individuelles la solidarité
doit el primer sur les libertés
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
à propos de la sphère alexeï navalni
l'union européenne a sanctionné
plusieurs proches du président russe
pour leur prétendue responsabilité dans
l'empoisonnement présumé de l'opposant
alexeï navalni et à la déstabilisation
en libye des sanctions qui vont nuire
aux relations entre bruxelles et moscou
a réagi ce jeudi le kremlin au
kyrgyzstan le président a annoncé ce
jeudi sa démission sa décision fait
suite à une dizaine de jours de chaos
politique et de manifestations émaillées
de violences suite aux élections
législatives controversées du 4 octobre
dernier des élections entachées d'achat
de voix et d'irrégularités selon
l'opposition le premier ministre
revendique avoir pris les fonctions
présidentielles
[Musique]
et on débute avec la situation sanitaire
en france est un point sur les derniers
chiffres santé publique france dénombre
30 1621 une nouvelle contamination au co
vide en 24 heures à la france devient le
premier pays d'europe à dépasser la
barre des trente mille infectés en une
journée
88 personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 12,6 pour cent et
dans ce contexte le gouvernement a donc
décidé de mettre en place un couvre-feu
en ile-de-france et dans les villes dans
les huit métropoles les plus touchés par
le coronavirus un couvre-feu de 21h à 6h
du matin et pour au moins quatre
semaines
elle s'était manuel macron qui l'annoncé
hier en début d'après midi jean castex
et ses ministres ont présenté les
détails de ce plan un plan pour
l'ile-de-france et les huit métropoles
les plus touchés par le corona virus et
et d'autres soit l'ensemble du
territoire français écouter comme dans
le confinement certains déplacements
resteront autorisés pour des raisons de
santé pour aller à l'hôpital où aller
acheter des médicaments dans une
pharmacie de garde
par exemple pour des raisons
professionnelles si vous travaillez de
nuit ou que vos horaires de travail ne
vous permettent pas d'être chez vous à
21h
si vous avez un train ou un avion qui
arrive ou qui part après 21h il faudra
le cas échéant pouvoir montrer votre
billet
si vous êtes l'autre les si vous devez
vous rendre auprès d'un proche en
situation de dépendance pour sortir
votre animal de compagnie près de chez
vous
comme pendant la période de confinement
il faudra pour sortir après 21h vous
munir d'une attestation prouvant que
vous répondez de l'une de ces exceptions
et afin de limiter au maximum l'impact
de ces nouvelles restrictions sur
l'économie bruno le maire a précisé les
mesures du gouvernement au coeur de ses
préoccupations les secteurs de la
restauration l'hôtellerie et
l'événementiel l'activité de ces
entreprises est particulièrement
perturbé par les nouvelles mesures et
notamment le couvre-feu de 21h à 6h et
c'est d'après midi bruno le maire a
annoncé l'élargissement de l'accès au
fonds de solidarité pour les entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés des secteurs de
l'hôtellerie des cafés de la
restauration de la culture de
l'événementiel du sport les fameux
secteur s1 et s2 bis tels qu'ils ont été
élargis par le premier ministre nous
leur ouvrons l'aide du fonds de
solidarité qui va jusqu'à 10000 euros
par mois pour ces secteurs
dès lors qu'elles subissent une perte de
chiffre d'affaires non plus de 70 % mais
de 50%
c'est donc un élargissement significatif
pour les entreprises qui perdrait non
plus 60 10 mai 50 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
et puis cette information concernant un
des anciens et actuels membres du
gouvernement des perquisitions ont été
menées entre autres des musées aux
domiciles et bureaux du ministre de la
santé olivier vers ans de l'ancien
premier ministre edouard philippe
held agnès buzyn et de six bêtes ndiaye
des perquisitions ordonnées par la cour
de justice de la république dans le
cadre de l' enquête menée sur la gestion
de la crise du coronavirus les
opérations se sont déroulées sans
difficulté selon le ministère de la
santé et de façon très courtoise et avec
la pleine coopération du maire du havre
selon l'entourage d'edouard philippe et
pour en parler nous sommes avec fabrice
di vizio avocat
fabrice di vizio merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france olivier ferrand on le
disait jérôme salomon et loire philippe
agnès buzyn si bête ndiaye à des pertes
y des perquisitions donc au domicile et
au bureau information judiciaire avec
comme chef d' abstention de combattre un
sinistre
c'est dans la logique d'une procédure
normale précis dans la logique
vous êtes des conditions de l' écoute
maintenant la législation danoise vient
chercher la vérité la cherche donc on
demande pas la vie pour obtenir les
documents qu'on vient les chercher et on
vient les chercher en grande pompe en
fanfare voilà c'est toute la machine
judiciaire qui se déploie escalade
impressionnante est un peu solennel mais
aussi parce que c'est nécessaire
le document on vient chercher dans ces
cas là principalement les mails les
mémos qui ont pu être enregistrées
envoyé sous des tipis
il a envoyé des mails et donc cesser les
gonades on m'a cherché on est venu
chercher les ordinateurs maintenant il
va falloir les exploiter et ensuite
interroger les ministres sur ce qu'on a
trouvé alors beaucoup se sont interrogés
au niveau du timing avec des
perquisitions au lendemain des annonces
des manuels macron est ce que c'est un
simple hasard selon vous soulignons
absolument vous n'aimez pas un schéma
vous imaginez bien que trois magistrats
la cour de cassation une criminelle se
sont pas d'hier soir je pourrai plus de
dix ans un restaurant après le
couvre-feu et donc je vais décider à
faire une perquisition et je vais
téléphoner cette nuit aux deux unités de
police et de gendarmerie pour les
dépêché nom était prévu
dans alors évidemment ça tombe le
lendemain les attentes du président de
la république là s'appelle coïncidence
et effectivement c'est un très bon
signal envoyé politique un très bon
signal politique envoyé au public parce
que c'est lui rappeler ses rappeler au
gouvernement
bah qu'il est sous le coup d'une enquête
alors le gilbert collard député européen
proche du rassemblement national a
estimé sur lci je le cite je vois
vraiment dans cette perquisition
ordonnée au lendemain de la déclaration
du président de la république par les
plus hauts magistrats
une vraie déclaration de guerre de la
justice au pouvoir politique vous en
pensez quoi que je pense c'est que
j'espère que la peur pour lui que
gilbert collard tant que politique
prêche pour sa paroisse que gilbert
collard effectivement fait semblant
d'ignorer ce qu'un système judiciaire
alors qu'il est avocat
moi je suis pas de politique fait le
droit d'avoir fait de la politique
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre en
tout cas de cette information judiciaire
qui s'ajoute à l' enquête ouverte 10
juin par le parquet de paris
que risquent les mises en cause
ce qu'on peut en attendre d'abord c'est
la vérité il a dit regretter on a
toujours un chant lyrique et ça c'est un
point contestable et effectivement pas
clairement ce qui va se passer c'est que
cette réunion va aller à son terme et à
son terme la commission d'instruction
dira si oui ou non il ya des fautes
pénales qui ont été commises s'il y en a
les ministres ont aussi leur explique
s'il y en a paraît pas très bien à 100
là on considérera qui aura pas mais au
moins on sera allé au bout et on aura
fait la vérité sur cette affaire
une vérité au bout de laquelle je répète
que la justice est la seule à pouvoir la
faire si on met de côté l'aspect
juridique selon vous est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a assez de recul sur
cette crise sanitaire inédite pour mener
l enquête et voir là où il aurait dû
prendre des mesures justice et pas
besoin de recul
tant et si bien que vous avez plus d
enquête de flagrance la justice et pas
besoin de recul
au contraire la justice agit dans le
temps de la traction ces mêmes vous avez
même rigueur vous savez aujourd'hui au
parquet vous avez un système qui
s'appelle le traitement en temps réel le
ttr aujourd'hui au contraire l'heure et
de la réponse pénale dans le temps de
l'infraction et pas avec le recul de
l'action c'est aujourd'hui quiconque
était pas dans dix ans merci beaucoup
fabrice di vizio d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat l état d'urgence sanitaire sera
donc rétablie à partir de samedi un
couvre-feu a été instauré on le rappelle
en ile de france et dans huit métropoles
la mesure pourrait être étendue jusqu'au
1er décembre sur le parlement
l'autorisait alors outre le débat sur
l'efficacité d'une telle mesure pour
freiner l'épidémie ou sur le caractère
opportun d'une éventuelle décision
politique à gauche comme à droite un
débat parlementaire est réclamée alors
le couvre-feu porte-t-il atteinte à nos
libertés individuelles la solidarité
prime tel sur nos libertés c'est l'objet
de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec julie
garnier porte-parole la france insoumise
bonsoir à vos côtés aurélien véron
conseiller de paris porte parole du
groupe changer paris bonsoir merci à
tous les deux d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pas plus de six
personnes à table en famille
interdiction des fêtes privées des fêtes
étudiantes partout en france couvre feu
mis en place à paris dans plusieurs
grandes villes
comment est-ce que vous jugez ces
nouvelles mesures et ce qu'elles sont
antidémocratiques pour vous julie
garnier ces mesures elle commence
surtout à mettre en avant le fait qu'ils
seront plus enclins à faire de la
répression plutôt qu'à faire de la
prévention de l'anticipation et la
planification
non heureusement ils font toujours peser
sur les gens ont la responsabilité que
ne prennent jamais à aucun moment ils
n'ont pris la responsabilité politique
de la crise dans laquelle nous sommes
à aucun moment ils ont fait en place
nous ce que nous proposons par exemple
de la planification ils font porter
uniquement les efforts toujours sur les
mêmes sur les gens et eux se défausse
totalement et c'est bien ça le problème
mais aurélien véron vous partagez cet
avis je trouve que le premier et les
moments liberticide c'est ce virus ce
virus tue seul herelius contamine à
grande vitesse et donc on ne peut pas
juste laisser se propager l'épidémie on
a vu ce que ça donnait en mars et les
cours sont inquiétants moi je mets de
côte à côte et le la mesure qui
effectivement liberticide mais qu'il
peut être utile et judicieuse décidé
pareille nouvelle macro de son discours
il a un discours qui les technologiques
qui - m'inquiète quand il oppose les
citoyens libres et se posent des
questions sur une société de citoyens
libres à des citoyens solidaires qui
l'opposent liberté à solidarité je suis
inquiet parce que derrière cette cette
improvisation on est dans
l'improvisation on est face à un virus
qui bouge
le gouvernement change son fusil
d'épaulé régulièrement en fonction
d'évolutions du virus
le discours en trame de fond du discours
de noël makoun me semble porter atteinte
à des valeurs fondamentales du pays que
sont en effet d'abord la liberté
ensuite la responsabilité lorsqu'il est
fataliste et d'écouté c'est comme ça la
liberté c'est fini non je crois de la
liberté on prend des mesures qui sont
temporaires des mesures qui sont dures
des mesures graves
peut-être nécessaire mais la liberté
elle reste un phare dans notre modèle
somme de penser français et il a
tendance à le piétiner un peu vite
alors là prêt confie la presse couvre
feu est ce que c'est un confinement est
ce que le parlement va continuer à être
absents des décisions qui sont décrétées
par le gouvernement sans aucun débat
parlementaire et dans quelle spirale on
entre cette mesure ponctuelle elles
répondent à un vrai problème mais
derrière c'est quoi ce gouvernement
qu'est-ce que jusqu'où il est prêt à
aller au nom de l'urgence pour écraser
le débat parlementaire
alors justement on va regarder les
déclarations de l'un de nos intervenants
hier soir il s'appelle denis jacquat il
est entrepreneur est pour lui le
couvre-feu après le confinement ça ne
passe pas du tout écoutez on est
définitivement et officiellement en
dictature mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à prononcer ce mot aujourd'hui en
france on a commencé par nous consignés
chez nous on a condom en continu et en
fermant les frontières je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui au mois d'octobre les
frontières européennes sont toujours
fermés et en gros en dehors de l'europe
vingt pays ou moins dans lesquels on a
le droit de se rendre ce qui est une
première mondiale
on n'a jamais vu ça nulle part sauf en
période de guerre je vous rappelle juste
qu'on n'est pas en période de guerre
donc on est officiellement dictature
d'autant que dans un process
démocratique vous le savez normalement
un maire qui est élue elle pouvoir sur
sa ville un président de région sur sa
région et qu'aujourd'hui c'est à nouveau
le pouvoir central parisien qui impose
sa loi sans même concerter les élus
locaux et les élus régionaux
on met définitivement et officiellement
en dictature des paroles fortes un de
denis jacquet vous comprenez cette
opinion julie garnier
je la comprends parce que
j'ai l'impression que mon débatteurs
découvre en fait que ce gouvernement est
liberticide avoir un virus ne l'est pas
ce sont des choix politiques qui font
qu'ils sont liberticides et le
gouvernement rei une à une les libertés
c'est garanti mme ça date pas du virus à
la liberté de manifester je vous
rappelle que aujourd'hui manifester
c'est juste un être un acte de
résistance
c'est ça aussi les mesures liberticides
et ça date pas d'hier ça date pas du
virus
il ya aussi la liberté moins fort mais
qui aussi mise à mal dans ce pays il ya
la liberté aussi de ce syndicat qui est
mise à mal
il ya aussi le délit de solidarité qui
existe maintenant avec emmanuel macron
donc je vais tiers des démos sur
liberticide il y en a énormément et je
crois que ça fait un moment qu'il aurait
fallu s'inquiéter là dessus je suis un
petit peu désolé de voir que ce constat
n'arrive que maintenant
non ça fait un moment qu'il faut
s'inquiéter des libertés qui sont en
recul dans ce pays c'est bien mais bien
évidemment et je crois qu'il faut
interroger sincèrement les mesures qui
sont prises
parce qu'effectivement ils ne vont pas
dans le sens de la démocratie c'est une
évidence et sa fédé ça fait des années
que ça dure
aurélien véron jeunes d'apprendre qu'une
perquisition avait lieu dans les chais
les doigts au doigt et au ministère de
la santé on a ce débat ce débat a lieu
sur beaucoup de d'espacé médiatique
je crois que la france reste un pays
quand même où on peut s'exprimer on peut
débattre
je constate juste que la décision
présidentielle tombe une fois qu une
manière un peu brutale
même si elle se justifie moi j'ai encore
des proches qui sont hospitalisés parce
que leurs enfants ont fait la fête et
qu'au contact de leurs enfants et en
trapèze floride était une version encore
meurtrière il faut ne pas l'oublier que
les australiens ne pourront pas voyagé
avant 2022 que de nombreux pays
européens appliquent un couvre-feu non
c'est une décision qui est plutôt
aujourd'hui en train de se répandre en
europe l'objectif est de préserver une
activité économique qui permet de
financer nos hôpitaux de financer nos
infirmières de financer notre pain
quotidien de limiter ce qui a trait aux
pages et le virus cet été car nous avons
constaté que tous les clubs steurs sonné
de quoi de la fête de gens qui se sont
pas rendus compte que nous étions en
pleine pandémie et qui ont vécu comme si
de rien n'était mais quand vous
des dizaines assemblée dans des rues
piétonnes l'été c'est très agréable
aujourd'hui on en paye le prix donc
cette décision de couvre-feu
elle n'est pas heureuse j'ai pas aimé
les mots utilisés par emmanuel macron je
me pose des questions pour l'avenir mais
pour l'instant c'est une décision qui me
paraît quand même assez approprié
vous partez tout à l'heure du recul que
nous aurions sur locaux vides on a vu on
a constaté des erreurs des médecins ont
porté plainte la perquisition a lieu
suite à des plaintes de médecins vous
gardien des éléments objectifs des
éléments concrets qui montrent que le
gouvernement a commis des erreurs
il n'empêche que le confinement général
a stoppé brutalement se déroule à tel
point que cet été les français ont
refait la fête comme si de rien n'était
ils ont oublié que nous étions toujours
en condemi mais on est face à un virus
meurtrier pour le mois entier on a
dépassé le million mort alors à
l'échelle de l'humanité vous allez me
dire l'hôtel france insoumise causé
c'est une goutte d'eau non un million
d'êtres humains qu'ils soient effacées
par un virus ça nécessite des réponses
fortes des réponses coordonnées des
réponses qui évolue dans le temps en
fonction du virus ne peut pas juste
croiser les mains et dire se croiser les
bras et dire je veux me liberté continue
à faire la fête
et puis si les seniors si les jeunes
meurent à côté des russes tant pis là
des semis rôle et 6 est d'abord de se
freiner d'enrayer ce virus en continuant
à l'activité économique
nous continuons à vivre julie garnier
cette jeunesse montré du doigt assez
régulièrement
elle est irresponsable selon vous dans
ce qui a été responsable si à chaque
fois de pointer du doigt les
comportements individuels sans jamais
pointé du doigt le comportement du
gouvernement où il fallait des mesures
fortes nous le disions mais ceux qui
n'ont pas pris des mesures fortes c'est
bien le gouvernement
il fallait faire il fallait mettre des
moyens dans les hôpitaux et pour les
soignants est ce qu ils l'ont fait n'ont
aucune revendication des soignants n'a
pas été aboutie avec leur fameux ses
bureaux c'est ça la réalité et ça a
conduit à quoi ça a conduit à ce que
aujourd'hui un soignant sur 3 veut
démissionner ça conduit à ce qu'il y ait
moins de lits aujourd'hui qu'en mars
c'est ça la réalité c'est que ce sont
leurs choix politiques il faut aussi
qu'on est dans cette situation
et j'aimerais qu'on point de ses choix
politiques mais peut-être que vous ne
les pointes et pas parce que vous auriez
fait les mêmes juste je vous ai pas un
tel objectif
non je ne trompe pas de marée jaune et
jules garnier vous terminez aurélien
véron voix pendant suite
allez-y
recruté il aurait fallu recruter des
enseignants arrêter avec ces classes
surchargées aujourd'hui on a des classes
qui sont à plus de 30
que ça soit de la maternelle jusqu'au
lycée et je ne parle même pas de la
situation des universités ou c'est
absolument invivable c'est ça aussi
qu'il faut pointer c'est que comment
pouvez me dire que dans une classe où
ils sont 31 en maternelle on peut
maintenir un protocole sanitaire tout
simplement on ne peut pas et ça il faut
pas lui ni ce sont des choix politiques
aussi qui ont été faits quand dans le
travail vous n'imposez pas le
télétravail quand vous faites en sorte
que dans les transports en commun on se
retrouve absolument dans des endroits où
on sur doivent à 10 cm les bouches des
uns et des autres
c'est ça la réalité des gens il n'ya pas
télétravail qui a été imposée donc ce
sont à chaque fois de mettre la
responsabilité sur les gens et mettons
aussi la responsabilité sur ce qu'ils
n'apprennent jamais parce que si on en
est là c'est parce qu'il ya eu des choix
politiques
ces choix politiques et fossiles et
dénoncé l'ong station d'autres nous
avait proposé notamment une
planification aujourd'hui non il n'ya
pas une planification c'est pour ça que
nous sommes dans une situation
d'improvisation total qui a une liste d'
incohérences aussi longue qu'une liste
de courses et c'est pas normal donc
s'est trouvée assise paszek ça c'est
trop facile de pointer les gens du doigt
sans jamais pointé les vrais
responsables qui sont les responsables
politiques
aurélien véron vous répondez quoi âge du
dernier mais tout le monde a sa part de
responsabilité mais ça m'amuse quand
j'entends la planification mise en avant
par que le domaine de la santé c'est le
domaine le plus planifiés defour vous
avez dans les hôpitaux français sont
1000 personnels qui ne sont pas des
soignants sont mises administrative qui
planifie le résultat de ce modèle de
santé avec des agences régionales de
santé
une haute autorité de la santé des
modules des comités théodule en tout
genre c'est que quand le virus est
arrivé
personne n'a su dire ce qu'il fallait
faire la planification ça aboutit
systématiquement à c'était le cas dans
la santé française à n'importe quoi
parce le planificateur
il est irresponsable c'est jamais songé
jamais sa responsabilité
aujourd'hui vous parler d'embauchés
alors ça mais ça m'amuse parce que rien
ni m un anesthésiste ses 12 ans d'études
vous pouvez pas juste claquer des doigts
et dire je
veut s'asseoir sp6 de plus ces douze ans
c'est très long on a vécu des dizaines
plusieurs décennies de numéros ce que
juste merci à vos amis socialistes qui
voulaient planifier la santé en disant
s'il ya moins de médecins il y aura
moins de malades c'est la grande loge la
navigatrice
mais ça marche pas comme ça à la santé
et donc aujourd'hui le domaine de la
santé est simplement rejoindre un grand
coup de ménage un bon coup de balai dont
la bureaucratie qui gêne les personnels
soignants
il faut mettre le paquet et non pas sur
cette bureaucratie médical qui planifie
résultat qui nous a mis dans l'ornière
pendant des mois mais plutôt sur les
personnels soignants qui connaissent
leur métier et qui besoin d'être
décentralisée de prendre des décisions
au niveau régional au niveau de chaque
hôpital d'une coordination clinique
privée hôpital médecine de ville
cette coordination elle se fait
librement les agences de santé l'ont
bloquée dans la planification a ses
limites
après vous pouviez mettre le doigt sur
un responsable on est tous responsables
c'est pas les jeunes certains jeunes
c'est pas l'état l'état a fait des
erreurs
ils ont aussi appris des responsabilités
les moments il le fallait le faire
ils ont eu raison le confinement il n'y
a pas beaucoup de français à part ce
concert soumises pour contester
l'utilité de ce confinement qui a permis
de passer un été et se rend compte que
ça marchait donc tout le monde est un
peu responsable tous m'ont fait des
erreurs c'est une situation difficile
moi je suis vigilant pour l'avenir et
donc je m'interroge encore une fois sur
cette méthode à l'avenir pour l'instant
on a des tests qui ne marche pas donc
depuis le mois de mars
on aurait pu y aura des tests qui
marchent en 48 heures en 24 heures
aujourd'hui il faut une semaine trois un
résultat les masques sont les avenières
grâce à la planification n'a pas marché
parce que là vous appelez la
planification les masques c'est pas
d'unification qui a marché ce sont les
grandes surfaces commerciales donc le
marché a apporté beaucoup plus vite des
réponses pratiques aux besoins des
malades que la planification au rayon
des tests ont laissé faire les
pharmaciens et les professions médicales
et non pas le droit de faire des tests
sans doute qu'on aurait beaucoup plus de
tests rendu en beaucoup moins de temps
qu aujourd'hui on va revenir à cette
idée de la solidarité finalement qui a
été mise en avant hier par le président
emmanuel macron un couvre-feu pour être
solidaire et finalement qu'il n'y a pas
de saturation derrière des hôpitaux
quel cette solidarité là vous en pensez
quoi vous jure
nier qu'elle est hypocrite la vraie
solidarité ça serait déjà de rétablir
lisf lisf vous savez c'est pas n'importe
quoi ces trois milliards vous savez ce
qu'on fait avec 3 milliards mark rutte
60000 sociaux c'est pas mal de recruter
60 mille soignants n'ont donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est qu'à
chaque fois c'est toujours les mêmes qui
sont épargnés à qui on demande aucun
effort et l'effort repose sur qui
toujours sur les mêmes
non il fallait si vous payez mieux les
soignants vous verrez il n'y a pas
besoin d'attendre 12 ans y en a qui
reviendront faire leur métier original
parce qu'il sait la vérité c'est qu'il
ya des soignants qui ont démissionné
parce qu'ils en avaient ras-le-bol
d'être mal payé
méprisé et qui étaient sous l'eau et qui
n'en pouvait plus voilà c'est ça la
réalité donc payer mieux les gens
offraient des conditions de travail
décentes fait en sorte que justement on
est reconnu dans son travail ça c'est
pas rien et vous verrez que bah vous
quand vous êtes entrepreneur vous savez
débaucher dans les autres entreprises
mais là c'est pareil juste reconnaissez
les gens à arrêter de les traiter comme
n'importe quoi arrêter de leur dire que
toute façon ce sont des bureaucratiques
qui ne servent à rien que les
fonctionnaires sont du trou de le trou
sociale de ce pays
c'est insupportable à force donc au bout
d'un moment quand on comprendra que
notre solidarité elle repose justement
sur ces services publics sur ces
enseignants sur ces soignants acquis à
chaque fois on ne donne on et
maltraitent on est mal paye et
d'ailleurs c'est pas nous qui le disons
ce sont les chiffres de l' ocde qui lui
disent d'envoyer le cd yeux ce n'est pas
une organisation communiste totalitaire
1 donc il me semble que il faut tout
simplement faire une vraie solidarité et
une solidarité qui justement met à
contribution ceux qui en plus je vous
rappelle quand même que ces dix
dernières années
les milliardaires ont gagné plus de 430
9 % c'est pas rien quand en douze années
le smic a augmenté de 12% voc les
dividentes eux ont augmenté de plus de
100% tout cas un moment quand on parle
de solidarité
j'aimerais qu'on arrête de racketter les
pauvres j'aimerais qu'on arrête de
racketter les gens qui vont dans les
urgences
j'aimerais qu'on arrête de racketter les
malades j'aimerais juste qu'on met à
contribution ceux qui sont les vrais
profiteurs de cette crise et qui à
chaque fois sont épargnés puis lilloise
quelques secondes
aurélien véron on vous laisse le mot de
la fin pour répondre la solidarité avec
le fusil sur la tempe je ne sais pas
comment ça s'appelle mais moi j'appelle
ça autrement plus tôt la servitude
il est régime ont fonctionné comme ça en
général
extrêmement mal et leurs enseignants et
leurs infirmières donc j'ai moyennement
confiance dans vos méthodes et je
rappelle encore une fois que la
bureaucratie de la santé c'était quoi de
ce que j'ai choisi un don quand vous
avez sont mille administrative dans les
hôpitaux plus sûrs des dizaines de
milliers de fonctionnaires ont les
agences régionales et qu'elle a faim
vous avez une crise comme le co vide et
que personne ne sait quoi dire
vous avez la réponse de la planification
c'est un massacre donc il faut revenir à
des règles beaucoup plus souple beaucoup
plus flexible payer les gens ça veut
dire avoir des gens moins nombreux mais
mieux payés
ça veut dire le nettoyage de tous ceux
qui sont derrière leur bureau conseiller
ceux qui sont devant les lits et qui
soignent les malades qui savent ce qu'il
faut faire en général qui sont pas
écoutés par leurs bureaucrates
donc effectivement un vrai modèle qui
paye des fonctionnaires qui sont au
contact des élèves au contact des
malades au contact dans la rue des
délinquants c'est eux qu'il faut payer
il faut un taux moins payer ceux qui
sont derrière un bureau qui fondait
d'après ce qu'ils demandent des
contrôles à tout le monde et qui
harcèlent et les enseignants parce que
les enseignants ont une vie
administrative qui est compliqué qui
harcèlent les médecins et les infirmiers
qui ont une vie administrative très
compliqué à cause de la bureaucratie
derrière eux qui font de la vidéo
lissiers voilà je pense qu'il ya un gros
ménage à faire dans l'administration
pour rendre des moyens à ce qu'ils font
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté le
débat ce soir merci avoue julie garnier
porte parole de la france insoumise
merci à vous et aurélien véron
conseiller de paris porte parole du
groupe changer parisse rester avec nous
sur rt france dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la sphère à navalni
l'union européenne mais le kremlin en
accusation dans l'empoisonnement supposé
d'alexei navalni puis direction le
kirghizstan après la démission du
président ce matin le premier ministre
revendique avoir pris à les fonctions
présidentielles a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
était assez violente d'ailleurs entre
les russes et les américains alors que
j'étais destinée à voler avec les russes
mais une opportunité s'est ouverte de
faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens qui m'a envoyé
aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs
on est loin de la guerre des étoiles à
en est quand même dans une espèce de con
fraternité et de solidarité
l'exploration au sens large est une
activité en coopération internationale
où on se rend service entre nations qui
pourtant au même moment son sujet
d'embargo et de conflits géopolitiques
savoir est ce que l'homme peut vivre et
travailler dans l'espace est ce qu'il
existe de la vie ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de notre planète
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sens du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soir
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
concernant la sphère navalni l'union
européenne sanctionne plusieurs proches
du président russe pour leur prétendue
responsabilité dans l'empoisonnement
présumé l'opposant alexeï navalni les
détails de notre correspondant à moscou
entre nick héros ce nouveau train de
sanctions qui touchent plusieurs membres
de l'administration présidentielle le
directeur du fsb ou encore un
laboratoire accusé d'avoir conçu le
novice choc a rapidement suscité de
vives réactions de la part des autorités
russes à commencer par le porte parole
du kremlin qui a déploré des nouvelles
mesures contre la russie dépourvu de
logique un avis d'ailleurs partagé par
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe
qui a en plus pointés du doigt des
failles dans les accusations de
l'allemagne écouter une autre question
consiste à savoir comment l'allemagne a
réussi à identifier le novice choc dans
les échantillons selon l'allemagne ce
pays n'a jamais synthétiser de substance
de cette classe mais l'a identifié sans
équivoque il faudra dresser la même
question laboratoire de loyat c'est en
france et en suède
et nous l'avons posée nous ne recevons
aucune réponse à nos questions
ce qui est aussi un fait la position des
autorités allemandes ne résiste pas à la
critique lui tient au lieu de mener un
dialogue civilisé entre les autorités
compétentes ashley ils ont préféré
lancer une campagne de propagande
caractérisée par des déclarations
tonitruantes ou plus au niveau 6 comme
ils l'affirment il possède des preuves
confirmant l'empoisonnement
qu'est ce qui les empêche de les
présenter à la réussite on signe de
bonne foi et pour tenter de prouver que
la russie n'a rien à se reprocher maria
sharapova a fait une annonce elle a fait
savoir qu'une visite d'inspecteurs de
l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques étaient en projet dans
le cadre de l'empoisonnement présumé d'
alexeï navalni au final la russie
regrette donc l'adoption par l'union
européenne de nouvelles sanctions qui
portent préjudice aux relations entre
moscou et bruxelles d'autant que ces
sanctions appelle une réponse au moins
symétrique de la part des autorités
russes le kremlin en effet promis de
répondre de la manière qui servira le
mieux les intérêts de la russie
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandre latsa entrepreneurs et
analyses
alexandre latsa merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france 1 l'union
européenne a donc décidé de sanctionner
plusieurs responsables russes proche du
président vladimir poutine
est ce que cela signifie que l'union
européenne dispose de preuves concrètes
de leur implication
écoutez vous saura puisque si l'union
européenne a des preuves j'imagine
qu'elles vont êtres vont être rendus
tout simplement public et un mais ce qui
est un peu un peu plus décourageant si
vous voulez c'est que depuis maintenant
plusieurs années le les relations entre
l'union européenne et la russie se
manifeste toujours par des des prises de
sanctions de l'union européenne vers la
russie
et c'est vrai que l'impression qu'en
fait que la relation entre les deux
parties se ne passe plus que par une
politique de sanctions et c'est assez
préjudiciable puisque de toute façon
cette rupture qui est en train de
s'aggraver avec ces sanctions entre la
la russie et union européenne en fait
elles portent tout autant préjudice à la
russie quelle union européenne et sans
doute à la france en premier lieu
comment est perçue l'empoisonnement
d'alexei navalni en russie
goûtez à l'excès navali a une image
assez importante dans la presse
française
un petit peu moins un petit peu moins en
russie il faut quand même le dire ça
reste bien vous savez instinct lanceurs
d'alertés un blogueur qui depuis une
grosse dizaine d'années un petit peu
c'est cissé revient fait des
manifestations de 2012 contre les
élections qui avait lieu à cette époque
là pour apparaître comme une espèce de
visage de l'opposition
il est quand même beaucoup plus connu
dans les grandes villes de l'ouest de la
russie notamment moscou et saint
pétersbourg et c'est vrai que là ils
étaient beaucoup moins connu n'a jusqu'à
peu dans le reste du pays
ça reste quand même une à quelqu'un qui
est un blogueur qui est un lanceur
d'alerté un très bon communicant mais
c'est pas une figure politique donc ce
qui est assez surprenant si vous voulez
c'est que d'un côté
finalement si gêné à ce point le kremlin
comme on semble dire dans les médias en
occident il est assez surprenant qu'il
n'ait jamais eu de problèmes plus graves
et et si vraiment il posé un problème
aussi critique comme semblent le dire il
est évident qu'il ne pourrait pas
continuer à faire ce qui fait donc
autant les actes et les choses qu'il dit
on sait notamment la corruption c'est en
inde partie des élites russes est
quelque chose qui a acquis qui réel et
qui existent et qui n'est pas un secret
pour les russes de russie et pour
personne en réalité autant
beaucoup de gens se pose quand même la
question de savoir comment ça se fait
que s'il devait être empoisonné pour
être assassiné déjà ça ait raté et
surtout pourquoi ça n'a pas eu lieu
avant ce qui est certain c'est qu'avec
synova n'y est peut être irritant à
certains niveaux pour les élites russes
mais en aucun cas si vous voulez ce
qu'il fait et ce qui ne représente n'est
considérée comme une menace pour le
kremlin sur le plan politique ou sociale
ce que vous dites c'est que le kremlin
finalement n'avait pas de réel intérêt à
voir
alexeï navalni disparaître non je ne
pense vraiment pas mais puis regardez ça
retombe encore une fois sur le kremlin
et ça entraîne des sanctions donc c'est
pas l'intérêt du kremlin ça me rappelle
la tragique affaire names of how
finalement c'est cet homme politique a
été assassiné et finalement c'était la
pire chose qui pouvait arriver au
kremlin aujourd'hui là quelque chose
qu'il aurait pu arriver pour plus traîné
pour le kremlin ces qu'alexi nabhani ce
soit décédé et je pense moi c'est pour
ça que les médecins les médecins russes
l'ont laissé partir ils se sont dit si
jamais il se passe quelque chose qu'on
ne maîtrise pas parce qu'il est
emprisonné ou et qu'on peut rien faire
et qui meurt on va nous accuser de
l'aventuré donc dieu merci c'est arrivé
et il est en vie mais voilà je pense que
ça aujourd'hui encore une fois le
kremlin n'a à mon sens n'a aucun intérêt
effet plutôt se demander à qui sert le
crime a et c'est sans doute c'est sans
doute là que se trouvent les potentiels
commanditaires
à mon avis c'est à dire il y a des vous
entendez des rumeurs il ya des choses
qui se disent à ce sujet là bah écoutez
c'est simple soit
on finira bien par savoir j'espère nains
soit il a il a des sponsors qui sont
sains
on va dire peut-être c'est un scénario
comme un autre qui sont fatigués de sa
non performance politique et qui donc
l'ont menacée soit c'est un c'est un
coup organisé pour le faire monter en
popularité puisque une des conséquences
de l'empoisonnement c'est qu'on a
beaucoup plus parlé de lui que
globalement il s'est avéré beaucoup plus
il est devenu un peu plus populaire au
sein de la de la masse du peuple russe
donc il ya beaucoup de scénarios et à
mon sens si vous voulez le scénario que
le kremlin aurait voulu assassiner mais
les ratés me semble paradoxalement le
plus improbable donc je vois pas du tout
pourquoi s'arrêter le k1 et ça arrive au
moment de nord stream 2 ça arrive au
moment qu'il ya un scénario et un timing
en fait qui n'est pas cohérent et
finalement c'est assez surprenant de
voir que ce novice choc ne fait pas plus
effet sur luc soûlé skripal donc
globalement wired peut se poser beaucoup
de questions et je pense qu'en russie
n'at on se pose beaucoup de questions à
ce sujet là et on se demande aussi
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un tel
engouement médiatique pour pointer du
doigt le kremlin alors dimitri peskov a
déclaré ce que ces sanctions vont nuire
aux relations avec la russie
quelle pourrait être la réponse russe
bon ce qu'on constate c'est que les
russes font preuve de beaucoup de
résidents cette repondération puisqu'ils
subissent des vagues de sanctions
permanente depuis cinq ans maintenant et
même s'ils ont pris des sanctions
on va dire un petit peu en réponse elles
sont quand même chaque fois pour des
rhénans traîne pas une escalade donc les
russes sont toujours ça c'est une
constante dans une logique un petit peu
de dialogues avec avec l'ouest avec
l'occident et particulièrement avec
l'union européenne et la france qui est
un partenaire à ces privilégiés
donc je il y aura peut-être y aura
peut-être des sanctions qui seront
prises mais voilà ce qui est assez pour
les élites russes encore une fois ce que
le climat aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
plutôt du découragement puisque sur la
durée ça fait maintenant plus de cinq
ans à ses 500 sur sanction donc de
toutes façons a des conséquences vont
surtout être plus que des sanctions
retour de la russie
owen wilson sans réponse la conséquence
principale ça va être que les éditrices
vont sans doute de moins
regardez à l'ouest est de plus en plus
regardées dans leurs étrangers proches
ou vers l'asie et ça c'est préjudiciable
particulièrement pour l'europe et pour
la france est-ce que vous pensez que la
russie devrait être plus transparents
sur l'empoisonnement d'alexei navalni en
diligence en diligentant par exemple une
enquête indépendante
je pense que c'est une bonne idée mais
je crois que c'est ce qui est en cours
puisque vous le mentionnez dans votre
dans votre sujet il ya des experts de
cette agence qui vont venir et je pense
que là on va pouvoir avoir une vision un
peu plus claire de ce qui s'est passé
voilà donc après vous savez si chaque
fois qu'il y avait des meurtres des
assassinats ou des décès lors de
manifestations politiques dans des pays
de l'union européenne la russie prenne
des sanctions en accusant les autorités
d'avoir tué des gens on s'en sortirait
pas donc je pense qu'il faut garder
raison
je pense pas que le carnaval ni dans
certains cas critique pour le kremlin
aujourd'hui du moins sur le plan
politique
nan mais par contre cette affaire elle a
entraîné des sanctions elle a entraîné
un arrêt plus approfondie et plus
puissante dans scream 2 et il faut se
demander à qui profite le crime
merci beaucoup alexandre latsa d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes entrepreneur et analystes
la crainte d'une escalade s'intensifie
au karabagh hier l'azerbaïdjan a frappé
le territoire arménien à une attaque qui
ravive le conflit entre bakou et les
dissidents arméniens du haut karabagh
le tout malgré un cessez-le-feu proclamé
samedi dernier en russie et des
manoeuvres diplomatiques qui se
multiplient solène gaudin mart unis
bombardé la petite ville arménienne se
réveille sous les décombres ce mercredi
dans la nuit l'armée azerbaïdjanaise a
visé des sites de lancement de missiles
sur le territoire arménien cinq jours
après le cessez-le-feu négocié en russie
cette attaque relance l'urgence d'un
accord de paix pris hier le président
russe vladimir poutine et son homologue
turc recep tayyip erdogan se sont
entretenus par téléphone un échange au
cours duquel ils ont réaffirmé la
nécessité d'efforts communs
les présidents ont réaffirmé
l'importance du respect de la trêve
humanitaire sur laquelle les parties
sont tombées d'accord le 10 octobre à
moscou
la dîmière poutine et rachael tayyip
erdogan se sont prononcés en faveur de
l'intensification du processus politique
en particulier sur la base des solutions
trouvées dans le cadre du groupe de
minsk de l'osce a eu l'espoir a été
exprimée que la turquie en tant que
membre du groupe de minsk de l'osce cee
apporteraient une contribution
constructive à la désescalade du conflit
de leur côté les états unis ont eux
aussi membres du groupe de minsk affirme
que la turquie a renforcé les forces
armées azerbaïdjanaises par la voix du
secrétaire d'état mike p o
il appelle les puissances étrangères à
la neutralité pour ne pas renforcer les
troubles des interventions diplomatiques
divergentes
alors que les risques
d'internationalisation du conflit au
haut karabagh n'a jamais été aussi élevé
en kyrgyzstan le président a annoncé ce
jeudi sa démission cette décision fait
suite à une dizaine de jours de chaos
politique avec des manifestations
émaillées de violence 8o les élections
législatives controversées du 4 octobre
dernier à des élections entachées
d'achat de voix et d'irrégularités selon
l'opposition le premier ministre
revendique avoir pris les fonctions
présidentielles françois tyszkiewicz ce
jeudi matin bichkek
des centaines de personnes se
rassemblent pour une nouvelle journée de
protestation lorsque la nouvelle tombe
le président du kirghizstan sort-on
belle jen bykov annonce sa démission
je ne m'accroche pas au pouvoir je ne
veux pas entrer dans l'histoire du
kirghizstan comme le président qui a
fait couler le sang pour tirant sur ses
concitoyens c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé
de démissionner une décision célébrée
par la foule réunie dans un hôtel proche
du palais présidentiel
épilogue d'une dizaine de jours de chaos
politique et de manifestations émaillées
de violences depuis 2010 des personnes
injuste dirige le pays
nous sommes débarrassés 2 inch'allah
maintenant tout ira bien
nous sommes très heureux nous avons
gagné courage et ma peau confronté un
certain nombre de questions
tout d'abord il est nécessaire
d'organiser des élections parlementaires
juste et honnête
puis d'organiser un référendum et
ensuite nous déciderons de la forme du
gouvernement présidentielle
parlementaire mixte présidentielle
parlementaire
en cause les élections législatives du 4
octobre dernier entachée de fraudes et
de soupçons d'achat de bois des
élections finalement annulé après des
manifestations violentes et l'occupation
des bâtiments publics par divers groupes
d'opposants désormais ex président avait
promis la semaine dernière de se retirer
du pouvoir une fois que le pays aurait
retrouvé son calme et organiser la tenue
de nouvelles élections parlementaires
mais sous pression de la rue et du
premier ministre nouvellement élu par le
parlement ce à dire japarov qui
réclamaient son départ immédiat
soros baie james des coffres a dû se
résoudre à démissionner c'est à dire
japarov nouvel homme fort du quai
distant à la réputation controversée lui
qui purgé jusqu'en début de semaine
dernière une peine de prison de 11 ans
et demi pour avoir participé à une
tentative de prise d'otage d'un
gouverneur régional
libéré par ses partisans le 6 octobre
dernier il avait fait annuler sa
condamnation par la justice en un temps
record
puis imposer sa nomination au poste de
premier ministre
en sortant ses partisans dans la rue ce
jeudi c'est à dire 'je apparente vient
de revendiquer avoir pris les fonctions
présidentielles
ex république d'asie centrale de l'urss
la plus pluraliste mais aussi la plus
instable le catésis temps a déjà connu
depuis son indépendance le 31 août 1991
de révolution et vu trois de ses
présidents emprisonnés ou exilés et pour
en parler nous sommes avec etienne
combier rédacteur en chef de novastar un
média spécialisé sur l'asie centrale
étienne combier merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors cette
démission du président à ce qu'elle peut
mettre fin au chaos politique
il n'avait plus le choix finalement
bonsoir merci de nous recevoir
a priori je ne pense pas que cette
démission va mettre fin au chaos
on est sûrs comme des missions assez
surprenante même de la part des plus
proches soutiens de ce régime bykov je
pense notamment à felix koulov qui est
un homme politique proche de soroubat de
bykov qui a aujourd'hui déclaré donc qui
a vu sur un match impeccable juste avant
qu'il ne démissionne et il lui avait
pourtant assuré qu'il ne démissionnerait
pas donc c'est une démission qui est
intervenue dans des conditions un peu
particulières on sait que sur une belle
jb kof a rencontré donc c'est à dire
jafarov qui est donc le premier ministre
et président maintenant par intérim
ainsi qu'un autre homme politique et
c'est à la suite de ces discussions là
qu'il a décidé de démissionner donc on
est vraiment sûr sur une sur une méthode
et une manière qui est particulière
voire complètement flou donc on ne peut
pas vraiment dire que c'est la fin du
chaos là en l'occurrence avec c'est à
dire jafarov qui à la fois premier
ministre et président par intérim
ils consentent l'ensemble du pouvoir
exécutif entre ses mains et donc on a on
aboutit à une situation assez assez
délicate où on s'est compliqué de
d'élaborer une les simplement de savoir
ce qui va se passer dans les prochains
jours alors à chaos politique mais aussi
des manifestations dues aux élections
législatives controversées du 4 octobre
dernier des élections entachées d'achat
de voix et d'irrégularités selon
l'opposition
pourquoi ne fallait il pas attendre de
nouvelles élections législatives alors
ça aurait été effectivement l'idéal le
simple le problème c'est que les partis
d'opposition eux mêmes n'ont pas réussi
à s'accorder du fait de l'heure de leur
désaccord en fait de ces partis ne sont
pas spécialement constituée depuis des
années donc sont constitués uniquement
où précisément pour cette élection donc
ça a été compliqué d'élaborer un
programme ou en tout cas une ligne
commune
ensuite il ya eu effectivement
l'émergence et l'ascension comme vous
l'avez bien décrits dans le sujet de
c'est-à-dire jafarov qui passe de
détenus à chef de gouvernement en cinq
jours c'est absolument incroyable donc
c'est finalement c'est je pense que le
dans l'idéal ça s'emballe di meco fort
et espérer avoir une opposition claire
avec qui discuter pour organiser une
nouvelle élection qui puisse être
justement plus libres ou en tout cas
plus transparente par rapport à celles
qui ont eu lieu le 4 octobre dernier
mais cela n'a pas été le cas du fait de
cette ascension de sadir jafarov qui a
tout de suite c'est comme vous l'avez
bien mentionné de demander sa démission
et finalement engagé une épreuve de
force avec l'ex-président vocalises
alors intéressant nous justement à cet
homme qui a profité du chaos c'est à
dire ge a part of il a été libéré la
semaine dernière vous le rappeliez
premier ministre qui revendique
aujourd'hui la fonction présidentielle
quelle légitimité il a est ce qu'il est
a mal à la manoeuvre depuis le début
alors ça je pourrais pas exactement aux
répondre sur la manoeuvre depuis le
début en l'occurrence au sein légitimité
par contre les assez contestable la
seule la première sa première nomination
donc le 10 octobre a été très critiqué
du fait qu'ils aient eu que cinq ans
députés présents pour sa nomination
alors qu'il ya 120 députés au jeu dans
aux jo korkuc neiges qui est le nom du
parlement kirghiz
il ya une deuxième nomination qu'elle
avait qu'a eu lieu donc hier et qui a
effectivement entériné sa sombre eux
sont son poste de premier ministre
là où c'est effectivement aussi
compliqué pour sa légitimité c'est que
aujourd'hui en fait pourquoi il se
proclame président par intérim c'est que
dans l'ordre constitutionnel après la
démission de son emballage bykov
le président du parlement canadien bec
issaïev aurait dû devenir président par
intérim mais dans l'après midi
enfin dans l'après midi en france mais
dans la soirée au kirghizstan il ad il a
refusé en fait de prendre de prendre ses
fonctions et donc la personne ensuite
qui donc est
prévue par la constitution c'est le
premier ministre donc c'est à dire la
part of qui allumèrent annoncé ça
aujourd'hui alors même que il grille
finalement la prévôté au parlement
kirghiz qui doit se réunir demain pour
examiner la démission du président donc
en fait tout va très très vite et donc
c'est un peu compliqué de trouver
légitimité on a plutôt de la sensation
qui veut à tout prix s'assurer les la
mainmise sur le pouvoir exécutif
plutôt que d'attendre que le parlement
fasse son travail et le nomme
effectivement président par intérim
justement si cela se confirme qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre d'un éventuel mandat
de cette figure nationaliste alors déjà
il va falloir avoir de nouvelles
élections tout cas déjà parlementaire
puis présidentielle la constitution
impose que après la démission d'un
premier d'un président des élections
présidentielles aient lieu dans les
trois mois donc aussi dans la
constitution le président par intérim ne
peut pas être candidat aux
présidentielles
donc soit c'est-à-dire caparof modifie
la constitution en un temps record c'est
d'ailleurs ce que suggère une des
personnes interviewées dans votre sujet
qui parle de référendum soit ce n'est
pas lui qui va représenter qui ne qui
doit devenir président et ce sera
quelqu'un d'autre de son entourage qui
veulent devenir
là en l'occurrence c'est un peu c'est un
peu particulier
on sait que en asie centrale en
ouzbékistan notamment à la mort d'islam
karimov en 2016 il ya déjà eu ce cas de
figure où chaque 4 mur de huy a été à la
fois chef du gouvernement et président
par intérim
ça s'est soldé en ouzbékistan par sa son
élection au poste de président mais la
constitution est différente au
kirghizstan et donc on sait pas
exactement c'est un peu tout le tout
l'enjeu c'est à savoir qui comment va
vraiment réagir c'est à dire j'adore
qu'elles sont ce qu'ils allaient son
programme
quand est ce que seront organisées les
élections législatives et l'élection
présidentielle s'il ya quand même
beaucoup de questions ce soir et on
suivra ça de près merci à vous etienne
combier je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de
nova ce temps c'est un média spécialisé
sur l'asie centrale et c'est la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve dans un
peu moins de dix minutes pour un point
complet sur l'actualité rester avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes un héros pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire des
expéditions se trouve savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être ma vie ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on va bien pour la 37
cantona un degré de plus de 38 en
médecine noblesse à une fabrique une
petite fièvre couvre quelque chose la
planète l année là aujourd'hui chacun
dans ses activités impact la nature
impacte notre question environnementale
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique
jean jaurès disait une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal
tout en comprenant le réel
[Musique]